bonjour madame
j'aurai besoin d'une carte européenne
pour partir en crète s'il vous plaît
l'été approche les vacances aussi et si
vous avez décidé de partir en europe
n'oubliez pas d'emporter votre carte
européenne d'assurance maladie une carte
gratuite qui permet la prise en charge
financière de vaud soit en europe
autrement dit si vous tombez malade lors
de votre séjour vous n'aurez aucune
avance de frais à faire vous serez
directement rembourser sur place par
l'assurance maladie du pays concerné
attention toutefois tous les types de
soins ne sont pas pris en compte
la carte européenne d'assurance maladie
permet la prise en charge des soins qui
sont médicalement nécessaires et qui
sont mot prendre non programmés ont ça
concerne tous les soins qui sont
inopinés c'est à dire qu une rage de
dents elle est pas prêts vont elle peut
être prise en charge en revanche des
soins qui sont programmés en amont d'un
huissier du départ dans le pays
européens ne seront pas pris en charge
pour se la procurer il suffit de faire
une demande en composant le 36 46 vous
pouvez également la commander via ces
bornes dans les accueils ou auprès d'un
conseiller de chez soi c'est également
possible en se connectant sur le site
internet
www.ameli.fr via un compte donc le
condamné lire reste un compte personnel
qui est gratuit et qui est sécurisée qui
permet aux assurés de consulter leurs
remboursements en temps réel et qui
offre une palette de services en ligne
comme l'impression d'être à 60 droit est
également la commande de la carte
européenne en cas de départ imminent un
certificat provisoire de la carte
européenne sera nécessaire certificat
est valable trois mois la carte
européenne d'assurance-maladie valable
un an est individuelle et nominative
chaque membre de la famille de l'avoir y
compris les enfants de moins de 16 ans
prévoyez une dizaine de jours avant de
la recevoir chez vous